thank you
it's seven o'clock this is a special
program live from New York where Donald
Trump will appear later facing a Litany
of charges relating to hush Money Paid
to an adult film star during his race
for the white towns
the former president
the first in U.S history to face
criminal prosecution left his Florida
Resort a little over two hours ago to
crowds of supporters
supporting his trademark Trump Force One
play and Bound for New York but we
expect him to land shortly before 9pm
he took off he showed a message on his
own social media platform condemning the
indictment he faces as a Witch Hunt
We'll Be Live throughout the evening
[Music]
good evening Donald Trump has left his
Florida bolto monologo bound for New
York for tomorrow he will learn what
criminal charges he faces
the former president has become the
first in U.S history to face criminal
prosecution the charges relate to
allegations made over hush money that
was paid to a pawn star during his
successful bid for the White House in
2016.
Mr Trump's motorcade left his Mar-A-Lago
Resort at around 20 past midday local
time headed for West Palm Beach Airport
in Florida
along the Route crowds of supporters
greeted the former president waving
banners and flags
shortly after 1pm local time Donald
Trump departed for LaGuardia Airport in
New York on his trademark Trump Brandy
Boeing 757 dubbed Trump Force One
as he did so he posted on his own media
platform truth social
Witch Hunt you say as our once great
country is going to hell
this is what will happen over the next
few hours and days
president Trump's arraignment the point
at which he's told the charges he faces
will take place in a New York court on
Tuesday
the following day he's flying back to
Florida where he's confirmed he will
hold a news conference at 1 15 a.m UK
time
throughout the day tomorrow we'll be
reacting to those charges here on Sky
News
my colleague Mark stone is on Fifth
Avenue beneath Trump Tower over to Yuma
James thank you very much what an
extraordinary spectacle this is I'll
step out of the way and you can I hope
get a flavor of what we are seeing here
on the corner of Fifth Avenue and 56th
Street here in Manhattan a sea of media
from around the world LED from their
front seats by the U.S media by the U.S
TV networks who with their own
interpretation of this extraordinary
moment in U.S history will be
broadcasting 24 7 for what I imagine uh
will be a couple of days at least and
over on the other side while you're
looking up there first of all at the top
of Trump Tower that is where Donald
Trump will be arriving in around an hour
or so's time his Penthouse apartment
three floors in itself at the top of
Trump Tower and greeting him over on the
other side of the road there will be
supporters of his they said that this
would be a homecoming that they would be
gathering to welcome him home of course
New York City is his home home but his
base is from far and wide across this
country and I have to say looking at
that number here it doesn't look to be
all that great the supporters are
certainly outnumbered by the number of
of media that there are here and indeed
by uh punters trying to get past have a
look here on Fifth Avenue the streets
has been narrowed um because the
barricades have been put up for the
media on one side for his supporters on
the other side and so people trying to
get about their business squeezed
between these uh shops and the road
itself as you say Donald Trump will
arrive here uh in a short while time he
will land at laguardia's airport which
is just the other side of the river here
from Manhattan there's some speculation
as to whether he will drive from
LaGuardia to Manhattan or whether he
will helicopter over and then drive the
short distance from uh one of the
helipads here to Trump Tower where he
will spend the night uh this night uh in
his uh the cage you might say up at the
top there before he appears in the dock
tomorrow for this extraordinary moment
in American in American political
history
foreign
on Fifth Avenue many thanks
Julie Randleman is with us she's a New
York criminal defense attorney
specializing in state and federal crimes
and investigations Julie many thanks for
being with us let me ask you the final
detail is still being worked out between
the days office and Donald Trump's
lawyers but talk to us about normal
procedure in the Manhattan District
Courthouse and the process going forward
expect obviously there's an indictment
that came down but we haven't seen the
specific charges yet it's it's what we
call an ex-indictment or silent
indictment and so we're not going to
learn the actual charges until court
tomorrow the first thing that usually
would happen and I expect to happen with
Donald Trump is he would come early in
the morning with his attorneys he would
go to the district attorney's office
where he would be fingerprinted and a
picture would be taken of him those
fingerprints are sent to Albany New York
for the purpose of uh getting what we
commonly call a rap sheet to determine
if he has any open cases warrants we do
that with every single defendant that is
arrested
that usually takes a couple of hours
once that's done he will be brought into
court
um and he will be arraigned meaning that
the indictment will be unsealed he will
be provided a copy of it to review with
his attorneys he will plead not guilty
now I know a lot of people are asking
the question will he be cuffed will he
not be cuffed there is no mandate for
any individual to be caught some people
think he'd want to be cuffed I'm not so
sure that's going to happen
um but there's no mandate that he'd be
cuffed in I don't believe that that the
District Attorney's office would require
that in a case of this nature
Julie we can't assess the strength of
this case until we we know the full
detail of the charges he faces as you
say that will only come tomorrow but we
think it's about a falsification of
Records we think there may be a campaign
Finance violation on the basis of what
we think we know so far how would you
assess the strength of that case
so yeah and unfortunately there has been
a lot of thinking we all keep saying
this guessing game because we don't know
the specific charges and we assume that
most of the charges are misdemeanors and
potentially some felonies they're I
would assume there would be uh if they
went into the grand jury and sought an
indictment and came back with a true
bill
um and so the question is the strength
of the case and the a case is only as
strong as the witnesses that you have
and the corroborating evidence and the
witness the main witness in this case we
all know is Michael Cohen or we believe
it's Michael Cohen and the problem for
the prosecutor in this case is that
Michael Cohen is a convicted felon
himself and he's been convicted of not
telling the truth in the past and that's
a big hurdle when it comes to the
prosecution going forward this case and
so the question becomes do they have
corroborating evidence is it just
Michael Cohen was there going to be
other evidence whether it be paperwork
emails audios other witnesses that
support what he's saying to be able to
prove Beyond a reasonable doubt that
Donald Trump is guilty of some or all of
these charges
as much told Julie about this being a
political prosecution Donald Trump
indeed calls it possible persecution led
by a Democrat a man who was elected into
the position the D.A Alvin Bragg I
wonder as a career lawyer what's your
take on that the accusation that this is
all about politics
so you know it's hard for me to assess
I'm not in the mind of Alvin Bragg and
so I can't tell you
um why it's happening or why it's
happening now I can tell you the talk
and the talk is coming from both sides
there's some sides that's you know some
certainly in the more democratic field
that say it's about time this will get
other jurisdictions to go forward with
the criminal cases that are potentially
coming forward as well but there are
some again from both sides who are
wondering why this case and why now
obviously there's another election
coming up and there's talk as to whether
or not the district attorney was
motivated by that political process to
go forward now again when an individual
commits a crime whether they're the
president of the United States or not or
the former president of the United
States Justice is supposed to be served
and the District Attorney's job is to go
forward but there's questions
questions about jurisdiction in regards
to this case there's questions about the
statute of limitations and again there's
questions about the credibility of the
witnesses and so all of these things
lead different individuals to have some
questions as to why it's going forward
um at this time
really many times
[Music]
also joined by Michael Wolff the author
of the book fire and fury an expose of
President Trump's White House Mr Wolf
many thanks for being with us it's
probably good news it's a tip for Donald
Trump when he arrives here to people
because he won't be in handcuffs
uh you know I mean this is this is from
from the Mar-A-Lago point of view this
is an extraordinary uh time and in fact
a and um a a time in which they they
cannot be more thrilled about this
um I'm being told that the pr that the
former president's mood is one is
triumphant at this point
um they tell me that there is really one
metric they are focused on and the
metric is that the more media attention
the former president gets the more his
poll numbers go up
um so we're we're in this uh a kind of
very weird moment in which in which you
have one half of um of everyone who's
looking at this saying the president is
in the former president is in enormous
trouble he is headed for court he may be
headed for jail and on the other side
you have many of of his supporters of
the people who are running his campaign
saying this has this has restored his
his political prospects he is back on
top because of this
yeah how would you call it Michael
trouble or Triumph
I you know let me go back to what
they're saying at Mar-A-Lago they are
saying short term this is
um only good news long term it's
uncertain but in the world of Donald
Trump long term doesn't matter because
everything is short-term everything is
the next Crisis which produces more
attention on Donald Trump which produces
higher polls
yeah Michael you've seen him close up in
the White House
talk to me about how he's handling this
indictment talk to me about he may
handle further indictments because there
are three others potentially more
serious in the pipeline how does he
handle that how does he well gain
traction yes no that's a lot of criminal
package
[Applause]
uh totally and in addition to the three
other criminal indictments that that he
may be facing he has several very
significant civil cases against him
including the the case a case uh of
sexual harassment by the writer ejing
Carroll which will begin in a couple of
weeks also
um so never before has um it it is not
just never before has a president been
in a former president been indicted but
never before has a president or former
president or politician of any kind of
stature faced so many so many legal
charges against him legal crisis facing
him having said that I can tell you what
he did this weekend did he worry well if
he was worried he he was worried on the
golf course
um so he is taking this very much in
stride very in fact pleased with what is
what is going on he's back feeling he is
in his element
um and with his element being all
cameras on him at all times
yeah his fundraising is up more than
five million dollars and counting on the
back of news of the indictment his poll
numbers are up and Republican yes ahead
of Rhonda Santos
why why does he have that constituency
that that follow-on behind events and
circumstances like this
you know I if if I could answer that we
would we would unlock the mystery of
Donald Trump
um the uh you know I think it just goes
to the fact that he that he is
fundamentally a performer
um he is fundamentally you know it may
be I've often thought that that it is so
clear when the camera is on him that he
is having a good time that somehow it
becomes infectious
um again it really doesn't matter the
the the quality of the attention good or
bad just the attention itself people
seem or at least half of the country
seems to take some incredible enjoyment
out of Donald Trump's performance
whether that is because they see him as
striking a blow for them which he would
maintain or whether they see him this
some how as just an ongoing extension of
his of his 14 years on one of the
highest rated television shows in the
country I don't know we don't know
yeah he's on his way to
New York and indeed Trump's plane has
just entered North Carolina airspace he
is on his way to Manhattan to Trump
Tower and then after tomorrow morning to
the Manhattan District Courthouse let me
ask you Michael
he has designs on a return to the White
House he was President once he wants to
be president again although he's had
those bones among the core support what
does it do all this to his political
Ambitions in the long run with
independent Waters swing voters those
that he needs to pull back in if he's to
succeed
well I think in a um
in a normal political calculation he
doesn't really care about swing voters
at this point he cares about Republican
voters in the Republican primary and
even more specifically I think he cares
about
um about what this does to his prospects
against the prospects of Ron DeSantis
the Florida governor and his
chief opponent in the
um in the coming presidential primary
although DeSantis has not yet declared
that of course is the assumption that he
will shortly declare
what can we expect Michael in terms of
strategy from Donald Trump moving
forward you think
well you know I think strategy is a word
that I'm not sure I would put in the
same sentence with Donald Trump
um it's uh from Donald Trump it's
largely impulse it's largely the the the
the moment at hand in how he reacts to
it
um often his uh closest aides are
dumbfounded by how he reacts when two
weeks ago he declared that he was going
to be indicted on Tuesday that would
have been two weeks ago uh Tuesday and
obviously that didn't happen uh that was
uh that was news to all to everyone on
his staff he merely uh sent that out on
his untruth social his his
um uh his um social media network uh
from the golf course
um whether he had been planning that or
whether it was spur the moment nobody
knows I would vote for probably spur of
the moment
um so so again it is all um for for
Trump a matter of playing it as it lays
um uh who's in front of him uh what's
the mood that he's sensing he is a first
last and always a performer
um and like any good performer it is all
about holding the attention of the
audience at a given moment
Michael Wolff journalist and author and
many thanks for being with us and for
your contribution let's go back to Julie
Randleman a New York criminal defense
attorney
Julie I wonder if I can ask you Donald
Trump has been withering in his
criticism all the D.A who's Prosecuting
or reading this case has also been
critical of the judge involved forcing
that the judge hates him I wonder and
you're a career lawyer how will that go
down in a New York courtroom
so the the question a lot of people are
asking is whether or not the judge will
impose a gag order
um on Donald Trump or on both sides and
it's very possible that they will um
they imposed it with regards to Harvey
Weinstein after one of the defense
attorneys spoke out
um almost directly speaking to the jury
and they're not bad piece and so they
could ask for a gag order the problem is
is what is that gag order going to going
to be it's going to have to be quite
narrow because they people have a First
Amendment right of free speech and this
is an individual that is running for
president and so he believes and his
team believes that this is a political
Witch Hunt and so he should be able to
speak about it and so the judge is
really going to have to do a balancing
act in terms of what that gag order is
going to look like by the way if there
is a gag order that there's no question
that his attorneys are going to appeal
it they're going to go either to an
article 78 like try to appeal it through
the state court or try to do it through
the federal court so there's going to be
a lot of appellate wrangling going on in
this case
than Julie much talk about other
indictments possibly in the pipeline
let's talk about this being the weakest
of potentially for prosecutions how do
you see it
well you know look you know we talk
about the potential from going to jail
this is and again this is a guessing
game but we assume if it is what we
think it is that it's a Class E felony
which is the lowest possible felony
there's no mandatory jail time and with
an individual that's never been in
trouble at his age even if he were to be
convicted it's very possible he would
see no jail some believe that this case
is going to push other states forward
other investigations forward open the
floodgates for them to come forward and
if their cases are stronger
um then this case will almost disappear
and the other cases will take more
precedent
Julie Randleman many thanks for joining
us and for your expertise just a bit of
breaking news a senior advisor to Donald
Trump Jason Miller has tweeted from the
Donald Trump flight saying that over 7
million dollars has been raised for the
Trump campaign pain since Thursday night
so Donald Trump doing well on the back
of news of his indictment in cash terms
at least we'll be here